everything you know everything you've
experienced has all led to this is that
my desk yeah
why do I have such a small desk because
you weren't that one lurch isn't that's
your snooze you lose I was under house
arrest ya guys hope come on we got to
focus on July 6 ready this this is
garbage
I got it at a rummage sale Ant Man and
the wasp get tickets tomorrow skillful
agile and fast
they call her the wasp she seems intense
it's got he unleashed something powerful
we need your help oh boy you owe us and
man and the wasp team enough
oh hey everybody its charlie I love the
way that they tie that to infinity war
this is the biggest thing you've ever
been waiting for and then he points to
like his crappy little desk like oh I
was under house arrest
vici can everyone for behind the camera
yeah that's why I wasn't around for all
the ashes just a couple months ago if
you didn't see it because they're on the
press tour they also did talk a little
bit about Avengers for an infinity war
I'll put a clip of that at the end of
the video it's kind of janky but it is
funny to watch them try to answer
questions about Avengers 4 so if you're
finding me for the first time there's a
new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video as I'm posting this video it's
Father's Day so of course everybody's
posting memes probably my favorite one
is Spider Man and Iron Man because he
has sort of adopted Peter Parker within
the MCU even though they haven't really
played it that way in the movies I
expected them to go there a little bit
more during infinity warp but it's still
kind of at arm's length like they made
the Batman joke is this your ward like
he's his Robin no that's not our
relationship and then you have the whole
tip-off about Tony Stark thinking that
he might be having a child with Pepper
Potts so like okay wait a minute what
are they trying to apply here last night
I dreamt we had a kid so real we named
him after your eccentric uncle what was
the name Morgan Morgan we were expecting
then there's all the Hawkeye memes like
where's Hawkeye on Father's Day remember
he had that newborn that they named
after Quicksilver for all you
Quicksilver cruisers out there that
still think that he's coming back
sometime my other favorite thing about
this too is the Matchbox cars that he
just grows it like he opens the
container they need that van so he just
pulls it out like it's a toy car of
course that totally makes sense that he
would do that if they've been doing it
with this building this whole time I
think the thing they've really done with
the Hank Pym character is lean a little
bit more into the comedy of it because
when they first introduced the character
during the original ant-man movie I
think they were leaning more into the
comic book Hank Pym the implied eeeh
this crazy temper and it was a little
bit darker now they're leaning more into
like he is the funny old dad man who
used to be this Tony Stark
industrialists with his crazy Pym tech
they keep saying that all these
characters show up during Avengers 4 so
I'm just wondering if we're gonna get to
see a version of the original ant-man
they implied that there were flashbacks
because we do see the original wasp
costume but we haven't seen a whole lot
of og ant-man
besides the flashbacks during the first
ant-man movie which is really brief and
like you don't actually see him doing a
whole lot you just see that flashback to
the missile where he's wearing the
costume but by all accounts the suit
that michelle pfeiffer is wearing and
all these promo posters make it look
like she is a badass in this film so if
one of the two of them is gonna be doing
anything cool it's probably gonna be her
but if you've been reading the comics
recently they've been doing a lot of
weird stuff with the Hank Pym character
a little while ago they fused him with
Ultron like that was their solution for
getting rid of Ultron Hank Pym was like
I will defeat him by becoming him so
it's sort of them taking the more
problematic parts of Hank Pym 'he's
character in his backstory infusing it
with Ultron his creation from the comics
so it's sort of like him becoming his
worst creation so was this weird
metaphor it was part of the infinity
countdown story if you haven't been
reading that Marvel because infinity war
came out it was this big infinity stone
story
Marvel Comics of course wanted to
capitalize on that with a big comic book
event the same way they did with Captain
America Civil War in Civil War two so
the actual story of it has no
resemblance to movie infinity war but if
you're big comic book fan they are
trying to do some interesting things
with trying to explain this multiversal
infinity gem story where you have a
couple Infinity stones that have shifted
realities so there's a couple really
complex ideas that I think that they're
trying to tease for Avengers 4
multiverse stuff I've done a couple
videos about how they can incorporate
the idea of the multiverse into the MCU
during Avengers 4 like him and Peggy
teasing the idea that we're gonna see
alternate versions of characters that we
already know like characters maybe in
the future like we have Scott Lang's
daughter that's gonna be a teenager at
some point during Avengers 4 but also
Evangeline Lilly making this comment
that Avengers 4 feels a lot like lost
season 4 where they shifted between
different timelines and different
realities so it's like oh maybe there
are other characters
present day in other realities that are
wearing the mantle of some of these
characters I've already done a big video
about that so I'll link it at the end of
this but we're just starting to get into
Avengers force stuff Kevin Feige has
been doing presentations they started to
show off what hoax new armor is going to
look like so I'll do separate videos
about that here's the interview of
ant-man
[Music]
[Laughter]
the big thing there obviously Evangeline
Lilly is in Avengers 4 but as far as we
know she only filmed about a single day
on that set
the Winter Soldier has also talked about
how he had scenes with Janet Van Dyne
and Hank Pym so pretty much every
character you can imagine has scenes or
at least one brief scene during Avengers
4 but some of that is probably very
brief like a couple frames big wide
crowd shots so when they talk about
people having scenes and Avengers 4 just
remember that can mean a lot of
different things but leave all your
requests in the comments below
and I'll name a new giveaway winner when
I post new Marvel there's an award show
that MTV is doing on Monday I think it's
the Teen Choice Awards where a bunch of
Marvel actors are presenting Aquaman is
going to be there so there might be a
couple big trailers dropping if anything
does I will totally do a video for it
but click here for that Avengers 4 video
and click here to learn about all the
big DC stuff that dropped this past week
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you